photo going around on the internet of
you and toby maguire
on the set of spider-man uh yeah the new
spider-man movie and uh and and i was
like wow i'm not sure about that
we are
we're pretty sure
we're pretty sure about it so
we know what's up do you know what's up
[Laughter]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and of
course spider-man no way home and today
we have a lot to talk about as andrew
garfield went on jimmy fallon last night
and jimmy fallon did ask him about his
involvement in spider-man no way home
and he even brought up those leaked
photos that we've been talking about for
a few weeks now now i think everybody
for the most part has seen these photos
by now if you haven't i am going to
briefly show one in this video i'm only
gonna show it to prove a point and only
for a split second but i will show it
later on in this video but we do have a
lot to address he did comment on the
photo and recently he also commented on
the sinister six and i know a lot of
people have a lot of questions about
what he said on jimmy fallon yes i saw
the tweets yes i got your tags on
instagram i'll explain everything you
need to know and we'll also have a
pretty good laugh because andrew himself
and jimmy fallon are having a pretty
good laugh as well and if you're new be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest mcu or spider-man
videos so i played a clip in the
beginning and let's start with this
because it's just hilarious to me photo
going around on the internet of you and
toby maguire
on the set of spider-man uh yeah the new
spider-man movie and uh and and i was
like wow i'm not sure about that
we are
we're pretty sure
we're pretty sure about it so
we know what's up do you know what's up
art
[Laughter]
so notice how andrew garfield just
immediately burst into laughter and i
think that the best part is is that he's
not even denying the photo he is simply
trying to play dumb but he doesn't flat
out deny it jimmy asks him about a photo
of him and toby maguire and he says i'm
not sure about that but jimmy fallon
says well we are and we've seen it and
then andrew just immediately burst into
laughter trying to keep it together this
is what he's been doing the entire time
in all the interviews when he is asked
about his role in spider-man no way home
if he's going to be in the movie he just
bursts into laughter this is kind of his
defense mechanism of not really having
to address it because let me just
explain something real quick because a
few people have been asking me why
doesn't he just admit that he's in the
movie everybody clearly knows by now
it's not that big of a secret why can't
he just come out and say it well even
though pretty much everybody knows he
still just can't come out and say it the
studio won't let him he signed something
called an nd a non-disclosure agreement
it's a contract that basically says he
can't say anything about the movie or
his role in the movie so keep this in
mind legally under contract he cannot
admit that he's in the movie until it
has come out or until he's shown in a
trailer or until the studio has given
him permission to say so now this is
clever marketing by sony's behalf
because look these guys have publicist
they're not just getting on talk shows
not knowing what they're gonna talk
about they know and this is great
publicity and it's clever except andrew
garfield is kind of all over the place
and kind of gives himself away here
jimmy fallon asks him if he's seen the
photo in which andrew replies in a
stutter might i add what what are you
talking about photo going around on the
internet of you and toby maguire
on the set of spider-man uh yeah the new
spider-man movie and uh and and i was
like wow sure about that
andrew goes on to say well if you show
me the photo i can tell you if it's me
or if it's fake and then jimmy of course
says well it's been erased off of the
internet the worst detective
well if you show me the photo i can tell
you whether it's it's me or whether it's
a real thing it's been a race he's been
erased off the internet
oh how convenient detective
but get this immediately after after
saying that he doesn't know what he's
talking about after saying that he
hasn't seen the photo he immediately
flips it and says i have seen it and
it's a photoshop around and we all saw
it and uh
i heard about it
and i did see it
and it's a photoshop
we say no
i'm trying to manage expectations you
say no oh you say no
after talking about how he has no idea
what jimmy fallon is even talking about
to saying that he hasn't seen the photo
to saying that he has seen it and it's a
photoshop he completely switched his
story to me this is a pretty big
giveaway that he is indeed in the movie
i think most of you know by now that i
truly believe that he is indeed going to
be in the movie even though we haven't
had an official confirmation we've had
pretty much every single news outlet
every insider say that he is in the
movie and leaked photos and here's my
deal with this leaked photo that you're
going to want to know about he claims
that this leaked photo of him and toby
mcguire is photoshopped and i did see it
and it's a photoshop which okay i could
believe that if we didn't have the video
the video is of the exact same scene of
the leaked photo it's the exact same
scene he is sitting in the same exact
spot that we see him in the photo him
and toby are on some type of scaffolding
and the whole background behind them is
a giant blue screen it's the same exact
setting and here we can actually see him
talk and we can see his whole body move
now it requires the 4k version to see
but fortunately i have the 4k version
now i'm gonna show this real quick and
i'm gonna tell you what to look for and
i'm only gonna show up close andrew
garfield because i'm really not trying
to get in trouble but at the same time
andrew did say it was fake so
yeah but here's why it's not fake if you
look at this really quick clip it's in
4k so you can clearly see that no
editing is done to his face if you look
even closer at his stomach you can see
his stomach moves as he talks and as he
breathes you can also notice little tiny
movements in his arms and his shoulders
i don't see how this could be
photoshopped and if it is whoever did
this needs to be working at marvel
studios at warner brothers somewhere
running their digital effects department
because seriously this is almost
impossible to photoshop but take a look
here real quick and again the stomach
moving is the biggest giveaway and the
4k resolution of his face shows us that
it's not edited so while i might have
believed that this could have been a
photoshopped photo because people do
that kind of thing all the time i do not
believe that this is a fake video i
believe that this video is real and the
videos have been taken down from the
internet people have been posting them
and the studios have been taking them
down they've been getting flagged on
youtube channels they've been taken off
of reddit and it takes a lot to take
something off of reddit they usually
don't take things off of there but
they've been taken off of all these
platforms why would they do that if
they're fake it just doesn't really make
sense i do believe this is just
promoting here this is marketing for no
way home without actually him having to
admit that he's in the film and it
actually is kind of smart because if we
look at the fact that we all pretty much
know he's going to be in the film but he
keeps denying it that makes us more
intrigued it makes us more invested on
whether or not he actually is in the
film and it brings more attention to the
film until we actually do see the
confirmation that toby and andrew are in
the film it's actually quite genius now
that i think about it and not to mention
he was recently asked in a different
interview about his third spider-man
movie that was supposed to happen with
the sinister six and he said that he
really wanted that to happen and he
thought that that would have been so
cool to happen well now no way home is
basically a sinister six movie with the
other two spider-man coming into play
now of course there is another option
there's the fact that he might be
telling the truth and he's not in the
movie and again i've said it before if
he's not i will be truly shocked i think
everybody is going to be truly shocked
from all the leaked photos that we've
gotten from all of the insider saying
that he is going to be in the movie from
the trailer showing us alfred molina's
doc ock it's showing us a pumpkin bomb
and hearing willem dafoe laugh in the
background from seeing lightning and
jamie foxx himself saying that he is
returning as elektro and the trailer
showing us that they messed up the
multiverse i mean everything is there to
tell us that the other spider-man are
coming so if they're not in the movie i
really just will be so dumbfounded and
really not know what to say but like i
said i truly believe they are and i
think we're gonna see that probably in
the next trailer hopefully but in the
meantime let me know what you think
about this let me know what you think
about andrew garfield's reaction to
jimmy fallon asking him about this photo
and telling him that he's in spiderman
no way home be sure to hit the like
button and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof